привіт, мене звати Олівія Лейнс, і ласкаво прошу назад до «Квантових обчислень на практиці» — це другий епізод: Quantum
circuits. Сьогодні ми розглянемо кілька тем, але я хочу, щоб ти виніс із цієї лекції три ключові речі. Перша: що таке IBM
квантові комп'ютери — щоб ти мав хоча б приблизне уявлення про те, що відбувається, коли надсилаєш завдання одному з них через
хмару. Друга: що таке Qiskit, що таке Primitives і як їх використовувати для створення та виконання Quantum circuits.
Ми також на загальному рівні розглянемо різні типи процесорів IBM Quantum та чим вони відрізняються один від одного. І третя —
типовий робочий процес для запуску експериментів у масштабі. Це включає вибір найкращих Primitives
для твого завдання, відображення задачі на Quantum circuit і застосування придушення та пом'якшення помилок, що дозволяє
вичавити максимум потужності з цих машин. Тут багато інформації, але залишайся зі мною —
незабаром ми зберемо це все разом на реальних прикладах. Спочатку коротко поговоримо про qubit та фактичне квантове
залізо. Як експериментатор, можу запевнити: це захопливо і справді допомагає зв'язати все докупи —
уявити, що насправді відбувається, коли завдання надсилаються на квантовий комп'ютер через хмару. Процесори,
які ми використовуватимемо, побудовані на надпровідних трансмонових qubit. Ось як виглядає невеликий процесор IBM Quantum —
ці маленькі квадратики і є qubit, їх тут загалом п'ять на чипі. Трансмон
сам по собі — це конденсатор, що складається з двох металевих пластин, з'єднаних паралельно з нелінійним індуктором, який називається
джозефсонівським переходом. Але щоб побачити джозефсонівський перехід, потрібно збільшити ще більше — він утворений двома
шарами надпровідного металу, що перекриваються, і місце їхнього стикання й є переходом. Джозефсонівський
перехід — це елемент, що дозволяє створити штучний атом із кількома енергетичними рівнями; ми виокремлюємо
два нижніх енергетичних рівні як стан qubit. Хвилясті лінії тут — це мікрохвильові резонатори,
фактично 2D лінії передачі, з'єднані з qubit. Коли ми програмуємо gate, це фактично означає вибір
точно відкаліброваного мікрохвильового імпульсу, і конкретна частота, амплітуда, форма та тривалість цих імпульсів змушують
qubit виконувати певні дії. Інструкції для мікрохвильового імпульсу надходять із твого комп'ютера в хмару, а
потім зчитуються і інтерпретуються кімнатною контрольною електронікою, яка фізично
генерує імпульси. Ми називаємо їх мікрохвильовими імпульсами, бо всі вони вкладаються в мікрохвильовий частотний діапазон,
що становить близько 1 ГГц. Після того, як кімнатні контрольні блоки створюють імпульси, вони проходять через кабелі
до дилюційного рефрижератора і зрештою до нашого квантового чипа. Сигнал надходить у резонатори через
дротовий зв'язок на цих контактних майданчиках, а потім передається лінією передачі до наших qubit. Я розумію, що це
могло здатися трохи технічним, і ці деталі не є критично важливими для нашого подальшого прогресу. Але сподіваюся, що тепер ти
можеш хоча б уявити фізичну систему, з якою всі ви скоро матимете справу. Де ж насправді існують ці квантові комп'ютери?
IBM має десятки квантових комп'ютерів по всьому світу, і нещодавно ми оновили наш парк до
процесорів виключно понад 100 qubit. Як я згадувала в попередньому уроці, частина з них розташована в
центрі обробки даних IBM Quantum у штаті Нью-Йорк. Ці системи розгорнуті по всій хмарі для загального використання, а частина
з них — виділені локальні системи з усією необхідною електронікою, що підтримують наших партнерів
з мережі IBM Quantum. Тепер поговоримо про Qiskit — відкритий програмний набір інструментів IBM
для роботи з квантовими комп'ютерами. Надалі я називатиму його Qiskit SDK. Є також екосистема Qiskit —
набір програмного забезпечення, навчальних матеріалів і функцій, що розширюють базові можливості Qiskit, а також Qiskit
runtime — сервіс квантових обчислень і модель програмування, що дозволяє користувачам ефективно
проєктувати та виконувати квантові робочі процеси за допомогою Qiskit Primitives. Primitive — це по суті невеликий будівельний блок, який
можна використовувати для проєктування більших circuits або завдань. Два Primitives, які найбільш важливі для нас, —
sampler і estimator, про які ми поговоримо детальніше трохи пізніше. Якщо ти ще не завантажив і не встановив
Qiskit SDK — саме час це зробити. Qiskit 1.0 нещодавно вийшов і він продуктивніший та
стабільніший, ніж будь-коли. Якщо ти тільки починаєш — прийшов у найкращий момент. Для тих,
хто вже знайомий із Qiskit, потрібно завантажити і перевстановити найновішу версію. Рекомендуємо використовувати
pip для встановлення Qiskit і Qiskit runtime та запускати їх у Jupyter notebook у будь-якому браузері. Також потрібно
встановити Jupyter notebook або Jupyter Lab, якщо ти цього ще не зробив. Усі ці інструменти безкоштовні, і ти
можеш запустити їх на своєму локальному комп'ютері без жодних витрат. Обов'язково додай Qiskit із залежностями для
візуалізації, щоб він працював із Jupyter і дозволяв будувати графіки. Також потрібно налаштувати віртуальне середовище Python, і є
інструкції на сторінці встановлення Qiskit, посилання на яку тут. Коли ти освоїшся з Qiskit і будеш
готовий запускати завдання на реальних квантових комп'ютерах, потрібно зареєструватися на quantum.com і створити IBM Quantum
API-токен — посилання також є тут. Детальний опис того, як це зробити, є в нашій
документації, як я вже згадувала, або можна переглянути відео зі встановлення Qiskit тут.
Обидва посилання є в описі. Ми майже готові перейти до Quantum
circuits. Оскільки мета цього курсу — навчити тебе масштабувати завдання до рівня понад 100
qubit, я вважаю найбільш конструктивним спочатку розглянути загальний робочий процес, якого ми будемо дотримуватися. Найпростіший спосіб
зрозуміти типовий робочий процес квантових обчислень — через Qiskit patterns. Qiskit patterns — це концептуальна структура, що дозволяє
виконувати квантові робочі процеси за допомогою певних кроків із модульними інструментами. Це дозволяє виконувати квантові завдання за допомогою
потужної гетерогенної обчислювальної інфраструктури. Ці кроки можна виконувати як сервіс і вони можуть
включати управління ресурсами, що забезпечує безшовну компонованість нових можливостей у міру їх розробки. Ось
основні кроки, які досвідчені користувачі Qiskit, напевно, вже знають. Перший крок — mapping. На цьому кроці
ми формалізуємо, як взяти загальну задачу, яка нас цікавить, і зрозуміти, як відобразити її на квантовий комп'ютер
у вигляді circuit. Далі — optimize. На цьому кроці ми використовуємо Qiskit transpiler для маршрутизації та розміщення
circuit на реальному квантовому залізі. Це включає перетворення окремих Quantum Gates у послідовності
WEBVTT
операцій, що виконуються на залізі, а також оптимізацію розташування цих gates. Далі —
execute. Qiskit runtime Primitives надають інтерфейс до IBM Quantum Hardware, що дозволяє запускати transpiled circuit.
Цей крок також включає використання технік придушення та пом'якшення помилок, які здебільшого можна абстрагувати від користувача. Нарешті — postprocess. На цьому
кроці дані безпосередньо з квантового процесора обробляються, надаючи користувачеві корисні результати щодо вихідної задачі. По суті, цей крок
охоплює будь-який подальший аналіз отриманих даних. Тепер ми готові обговорити основу квантових
програм — Quantum circuits. Сподіваюся, ти вже знайомий із Quantum circuits, але якщо ні — радимо спочатку переглянути урок
три «Quantum circuits» із серії «Understanding Quantum Information and Computation», посилання нижче. Тут ми зробимо лише
короткий огляд. Quantum circuit — це мережа квантових gates і вимірювань, з'єднаних
дротами, що представляють qubit. Quantum circuits можна читати як нотний запис — зліва направо, починаючи з
нульового моменту часу зліва. Віртуальні qubit — тобто qubit, ще не призначені фізичному
qubit на процесорі — перераховані у зростаючому порядку зверху вниз. Після налаштування circuit можна
додавати gates. Однокубітні gates, як-от ось цей Hadamard gate, впливають лише на qubit, на дроті якого розміщені. Багатокубітні
gates, як-от CNOT, впливають на два або більше qubit, з'єднаних цим gate. У цьому прикладі стан qubit один змінюється
залежно від того, яким є стан qubit нуль. Після застосування всіх gates можна виконати вимірювання,
що записують результати до класичних регістрів. Одна особливо важлива характеристика
circuit — її глибина. Глибина Quantum circuit — це мінімальна кількість шарів квантових gates, що виконуються
паралельно, необхідних для завершення обчислення, визначеного circuit. Зауважу, що Quantum Gates можна виконувати
паралельно, тобто одночасно, якщо вони не мають спільних qubit. Але якщо два або більше
gates діють на одні й ті самі qubit, виконати їх паралельно неможливо — доводиться виконувати послідовно. Оскільки gates потребують часу для
реалізації, глибина circuit приблизно відповідає часу, необхідному квантовому комп'ютеру для виконання
circuit. Тому знання глибини circuit важливе для розуміння того, чи можна її використати на конкретному пристрої. Це також підкаже нам, чи є
шанс отримати точний результат. Далі перейдімо до вибору квантового процесора. IBM
нещодавно випустила цілий новий парк процесорів, усі з кількістю понад 100 qubit, і ти можеш увійти на quantum.com, щоб переглянути,
які процесори тобі доступні. Усі процесори названі на честь птахів з певних причин, і різні логотипи
позначають різні типи процесорів. Наприклад, ці позначають процесори Eagle, а цей значок — Heron.
Назви конкретних процесорів також вказані вгорі — вони всі названі на честь міст, але це
не обов'язково означає, що процесор фізично розташований у цьому місті — це просто назви. Кількість qubit,
EPLG і CLOPS — ще фактори, які вказані там. Розглянемо кожен із них.
Qubit — тут все досить зрозуміло: qubit — це просто загальна кількість qubit, доступних на цьому окремому квантовому процесорі або
QPU. EPLG розшифровується як errors per layered gate — помилки на шарований gate; вимірює середню похибку процесу gate у шарованому ланцюжку з
100 qubit. По суті, чим менше це число — тим краще. CLOPS розшифровується як circuit layer operations per second і
вимірює, скільки шарів circuit квантового об'єму — а це віртуальний circuit — QPU може виконати за одиницю часу.
Чим вище число — тим швидше обчислення. Це еквівалент FLOPS у класичних обчисленнях. Ці
різні метрики можуть бути більш або менш важливими залежно від конкретної сфери застосування. Далі на загальному рівні обговоримо
mapping до Quantum circuits. Перший крок — крок mapping, що по суті відповідає на запитання: як
перетворити мою задачу на Quantum circuit, що може виконуватися на квантовому залізі? Без сумніву,
mapping — складна задача, і це активна сфера досліджень. Іноді вже сама можливість взяти обчислювальну
задачу і придумати послідовність квантових gates для її вирішення — найскладніша частина. Немає безвідмовного
методу, що гарантує успіх, але є рекомендовані настанови і приклади задач, для яких ми вже знаємо, як
їх відображати. Перша настанова: дай класичним комп'ютерам виконувати ту роботу, з якою вони краще справляються.
Завдання, що легко вирішуються класично, навряд чи отримають перевагу від квантового комп'ютера. Квантові комп'ютери — для задач, що є складними класично. Звісно,
якщо це твоє перше знайомство з Qiskit або квантовим комп'ютером, не переймайся пошуком обчислювально складної задачі. Розбий
її на менші підзадачі, яких можна навчитися розв'язувати, перш ніж одразу братися за проєкт утилітарного масштабу. Далі — переклади
результати своєї задачі, які потрібно виміряти або зрозуміти, у задачу пошуку очікуваного значення або задачу семплювання.
Для більшості типів задач це фактично відповідає обчисленню функції вартості. Функція вартості — це
специфічна для задачі функція, що визначає мету задачі як щось, що потрібно мінімізувати або максимізувати, і вони можуть
використовуватися для оцінки того, наскільки добре пробний стан або рішення досягає цієї мети.
Ця концепція може застосовуватися до різних сфер: хімії, машинного навчання, фінансів, оптимізації тощо.
Також майте на увазі, що залізо, яке ти будеш використовувати, має певну топологію: деякі qubit не з'єднані,
а деякі — так. Зрештою, потрібно буде відобразити свою задачу на circuit, що відповідає цій топології. Процесори IBM Quantum
використовують так звану топологію важкого шестикутника, що по суті означає з'єднання qubit у шестикутній решітці,
про що ми детальніше поговоримо пізніше в курсі. Зараз найважливіше пам'ятати, що цей етап потребує
практики. Потрібно добре розуміти не лише свою задачу, але й можливості квантового заліза,
і ми розглянемо конкретний приклад і варіант використання пізніше, щоб побачити, як їх найкраще
збалансувати. Тепер розберемо, як оптимізувати circuit для обраного заліза. Загальна мета кроку
оптимізації — відобразити всі віртуальні qubit із нашого circuit на реальні qubit у
топології процесора. Головне — максимально зменшити кількість помилок. Для цього спочатку потрібно
ефективно виконати маршрутизацію та розміщення нашого circuit. Перше, що потрібно пам'ятати: не всі qubit з'єднані, як
я вже казала. Деякі знаходяться досить далеко один від одного на чипі, тому потрібно зменшити або усунути взаємодії на великій відстані
де це можливо. Можна застосувати послідовність SWAP gates між сусідніми qubit для переміщення
інформації qubit, але SWAP gates є дорогими і схильними до помилок, тому можуть бути кращі способи це зробити. Далі — розміщення
WEBVTT
і маршрутизація — це ітеративні процеси, що призначають віртуальний qubit твого circuit фізичному qubit на
залізі. Це можна зробити вручну, але є також інструменти в Qiskit, що можуть давати рекомендації щодо фізичного
розміщення qubit на основі наближених значень рівня помилок. Далі можна об'єднувати послідовності однокубітних gates, що діють на той самий qubit,
в один gate, а також іноді позбуватися зайвих gates або комбінацій gates. Наприклад,
деякі комбінації gates можна спростити до простіших, і іноді комбінації gates навіть
зводяться до простого оператора тотожності, тому їх можна просто прибрати. Це можна зробити автоматично за допомогою
Qiskit transpiler або вручну, gate за gate, якщо є вагома причина і потрібен
більший контроль. Після покращення розміщення circuit, маршрутизації та кількості gates — вручну або за допомогою Qiskit transpiler — ми
зазвичай хочемо візуалізувати circuit, щоб переконатися, що часування всіх gates має сенс. У transpiler є аргумент,
яким можна скористатися для візуалізації часової шкали circuit і перевірки того, що все вирівняно так, як очікується. Тепер поговоримо про
придушення помилок. Придушення помилок — це різноманітні техніки, що трансформують circuit під час компіляції для мінімізації помилок.
Це відрізняється від пом'якшення помилок, яке відбувається після того, як circuit вже було запущено, і до цього ми повернемося згодом. Два найпоширеніших методи
придушення помилок, якими ми користуємося, — це dynamical decoupling і Pauli twirling. Тут буде деяка
технічна деталізація, але до неї завжди можна повернутися пізніше. Отже, перший — dynamical decoupling — використовується для
ефективного скасування частини шуму, що впливає на qubit, шляхом застосування серії gates, які разом дорівнюють
операції тотожності, як-от послідовності XX, і чий сумарний ефект полягає у приблизному скасуванні каналів шуму, що впливають на
qubit. Pauli twirling — це спосіб вставляти випадкові gates для спрощення середнього шуму. Випадковість допомагає
запобігти накопиченню ефектів від різних помилок і також полегшує характеризацію шуму.
Цей метод також лежить в основі техніки пом'якшення помилок, яку ми обговоримо пізніше.
Ще раз — тут багато інформації, і не хвилюйся, якщо все не засвоюється одразу. На щастя, багато з цього можна зробити автоматично за допомогою Qiskit
transpiler. Транспіляція може бути складною, але вона є настільки критично важливим кроком для досягнення корисності у масштабі,
що вимагає багато проб і помилок для опанування та отримання найкращих результатів. Хочу зробити короткий
відступ і детальніше розглянути Qiskit transpiler та його можливості. Зроблю це на дуже загальному рівні, а деталі та
приклади розглянемо пізніше. Загалом, транспіляція — це процес переписування вхідного circuit відповідно до
топології конкретного квантового пристрою та оптимізації circuit для виконання і стійкості до шуму. Вона також
переписує circuit у базові gates обраного конкретного квантового процесора. Qiskit має чотири
вбудованих конвеєри транспіляції, і якщо ти ще не знайомий з оптимізацією Quantum circuit, я однозначно рекомендую використовувати один із цих
вбудованих конвеєрів. За замовчуванням transpiler включає шість кроків: initialization,
layout, routing, translation, optimization і scheduling. Initialization — це
будь-який початковий прохід, необхідний перед вбудовуванням circuit на backend. Зазвичай це включає
розгортання кастомних інструкцій і перетворення circuit лише на однокубітні та двокубітні gates. Крок layout призначає
layout — відображення віртуальних qubit у circuit на фізичні qubit на backend. Routing виконується після застосування layout і
вставляє gates, наприклад SWAP gates, в оригінальний circuit, щоб зробити його сумісним із зв'язністю backend.
Четвертий крок — translation: на цьому кроці gates у circuit перетворюються на базовий набір цільового
backend. Далі — optimization: на цьому кроці виконується основний цикл оптимізації
повторно, доки не буде виконано певну умову, наприклад досягнення певної цільової глибини. Є чотири різних рівні оптимізації,
доступних для вибору. Останній — scheduling: цей крок для будь-яких апаратно-залежних проходів планування; на загальному рівні
scheduling можна розуміти як вставку затримок у circuit для врахування будь-якого часу простою qubit
між виконанням інструкцій. Отже, як я сказала, є чотири рівні оптимізації — від 0 до 3, де
вищі рівні оптимізації вимагають більше часу та обчислювальних ресурсів, але можуть дати кращий circuit у підсумку.
Рівень оптимізації 0 призначений для експериментів з характеризації пристрою і тому лише відображає вхідний circuit на
обмеження цільового backend, не виконуючи жодної оптимізації. Рівень оптимізації 3
витрачає найбільше зусиль на оптимізацію circuit, однак оскільки багато технік оптимізації в
transpiler базуються на евристиках, більші обчислювальні зусилля не завжди призводять до покращення
якості вихідного circuit. Якщо це тебе цікавить — перегляньте сторінки transpiler в документації Qiskit,
посилання нижче. Тепер ми готові обговорити фактичне виконання Quantum circuit.
Qiskit runtime Primitives надають інтерфейс до IBM Quantum Hardware і також абстрагують придушення та
пом'якшення помилок від користувача. Sampler primitive повертає квазі-розподіл імовірностей або підрахунки,
що представляють імовірність вимірювання певних бітових рядків — нулів і одиниць. Estimator primitive повертає очікувані
значення спостережуваних, що відповідають фізичним величинам. Трохи детальніше: sampler запускає circuit
кілька разів на квантовому пристрої, виконуючи вимірювання на кожному запуску та формуючи
розподіл імовірностей із відновлених бітових рядків. Чим більше запусків (або «пострілів») виконується, тим точніші результати,
але це вимагає більше часу та квантових ресурсів. Зокрема, він обчислює імовірність отримання кожного можливого стану стандартного базису шляхом вимірювання стану, підготованого circuit. Qiskit
estimator використовує складний алгебраїчний процес для оцінки очікуваного значення на реальному квантовому пристрої шляхом
розкладання спостережуваного на комбінацію інших спостережуваних із відомими власними базисами і запуску під
капотом Primitives — це техніки, що називаються пом'якшенням помилок. Пом'якшення помилок — це узагальнений термін для всього цього, і воно
по суті стосується технік, що дозволяють нам зменшити помилки circuit шляхом моделювання шуму пристрою під час
виконання. Зазвичай це призводить до накладних витрат квантової попередньої обробки, пов'язаних з навчанням моделі, і класичної
постобробки для пом'якшення помилок у сирих результатах за допомогою згенерованої моделі. Але в обмін на ці накладні витрати
ми отримуємо значно точніші результати. Є кілька технік, які можна реалізувати для
пом'якшення помилок, і ми детальніше розглянемо три з них. Але майте на увазі, що це активна сфера
WEBVTT
досліджень, тому, швидше за все, будуть винайдені нові техніки, а старі продовжуватимуть вдосконалюватися. Рівень
стійкості збільшує витрати — або, іншими словами, час, необхідний для виконання твого завдання. Ми вже сказали, що при
рівні стійкості 0 transpiler фактично нічого не робить із твоїм circuit, але починаючи з рівня стійкості 1 він вводить метод під назвою twirled
readout error extinction, або скорочено T-REx. Twirled readout error extinction використовує Pauli twirling для
пом'якшення шуму — щось, чого ми вже торкнулися. Це дуже загальна та ефективна техніка, яка
інтуїтивно робить шум менш нерегулярним і легшим для обробки. Починаючи з рівня стійкості 2 ми
вводимо zero noise extrapolation, або скорочено ZNE. Це популярна техніка, з якою ми нещодавно мали багато
успіхів. Ідея ZNE може здатися трохи дивовижною: ми насправді додаємо додатковий
шум поверх вже наявного, але це дозволяє нам екстраполювати у зворотньому напрямку для
передбачення того, якими будуть результати при меншому шумі. Це можна зробити кількома конкретними способами. Наприклад, можна
розтягнути gates, щоб зробити їх довшими і, таким чином, більш схильними до помилок, або можна запустити більше gates, які в підсумку
дають операцію тотожності, тому circuit функціонально не змінюється, але ми навмисно семплюємо більше
шуму. Однак це потрібно робити для кожного circuit і кожного очікуваного значення, яке потрібно відстежувати, тому можна
побачити, як це може стати дуже дорогим з точки зору необхідного часу. Один конкретний тип ZNE називається
probabilistic error amplification, або PEA скорочено. Після того як ми навчилися модель шуму для gate, PEA
працює шляхом семплювання помилок із тієї моделі шуму і навмисного їх вкидання в circuit. Як я згадувала, багато нових
технік продовжує розроблятися і сподіваємося, що вони будуть реалізовані, коли ми побачимо більше і більше з них у дії. Є лише одна остання форма
пом'якшення помилок, яку я хочу обговорити, — probabilistic error cancellation. На відміну від того, щоб бути на третьому рівні стійкості,
PEC — це особлива можливість, яку потрібно вмикати вручну в Qiskit, оскільки обчислювальні ресурси,
необхідні для неї, не масштабуються так добре порівняно з іншими техніками пом'якшення помилок, які ми обговорювали. Ти
починаєш з вивчення шуму, що впливає на твій circuit, запускаючи noise learning або circuits для характеризації шуму
для кожного унікального шару двокубітних gates у твоєму circuit. Ці результати дозволяють описати шум
у термінах операторів Паулі. Коли знаєш ці шумові члени, можна модифікувати свої circuits так,
щоб вони ефективно мали вбудований протилежний PEC для скасування цих шумових каналів. У певному сенсі цей процес
схожий на навушники з шумопоглинанням, однак цей спосіб скасування шуму є дуже затратним — час виконання
зростає експоненційно зі збільшенням кількості gates, тому це може бути не найкращим вибором для дуже великого circuit. Ми
тепер дійшли до фінального етапу — postprocessing. Зрештою, якщо ти добре попрацював і застосував належні техніки пом'якшення помилок,
ти можеш побачити, як твоя фінальна відповідь зміниться, як-от у цій фігурі: немігований розподіл,
показаний фіолетовим, досить далеко від справжнього очікуваного значення, показаного тут цією лінією. Однак після застосування пом'якшення помилок
ми отримуємо мігований розподіл, показаний синім, що має пік значно ближче до справжнього значення. Тепер,
все це має свою ціну, і тут ми бачимо, що дисперсія або ширина розподілу збільшується, що
загалом не те, що потрібно. Але все має свою ціну. На щастя, ми можемо врахувати це, запустивши більше
«пострілів», що призводить до звуження розподілу до прийнятного рівня невизначеності. Ось і все на цей
урок. Наступного разу ми зберемо всі ці кроки разом і розглянемо реальний приклад із
цікавою прикладною сферою. Є кілька речей, які я можу порекомендувати зробити до тоді. Якщо ще не зробив —
завантаж і налаштуй Qiskit 1.0. Також можеш переглянути відповідний урок до цього розділу і
попередній епізод на навчальній платформі IBM Quantum Learning. І насамкінець, якщо тебе цікавить глибше занурення та
вивчення технік пом'якшення помилок — перегляньте одне з численних джерел, посилання на які я додала нижче. До наступного разу!
[Музика]